you have not seen what I've seen I have
seen my share the rings of power has
definitely held some power over the
lives of the stunt actors some of the
worst injuries we've heard of in a long
time happened on this set but there were
also some beautiful moments of actors
overcoming their fears I don't want a
stunt double number one this one is
truly a waking night
marvid got through this we'll never know
once an elf sets her mind to something
it's quite terrifying because she will
go in and now here's for a really
stressful moment the water stuff was
something I'd always found quite
frightening Marvin Clark is basically
terrified of her own shadow so you can
imagine how she felt knowing what was
coming for her I was tied underwater
that's right she was tied underwater for
an hour and a half without actually
being able to come up for air so that
was something I didn't expect to be able
to do she of course had access to oxygen
to use a breather she also had to do
scuba training to prepare for this
moment the crazy part is she actually
found the situation rather Zen nope nope
nope nope nope that's a million nopes
from us thanks we do not encourage
underwater therapy
number two this one's a Tale As Old As
Time costumes almost never reflect the
filming weather it was boiling on set so
for actor Owen Arthur with a thick
wintry costume Prosthetics glue and that
16-piece beard attached to his face and
covering a solid portion of his body he
was burning up that's for sure they had
to add a cooling vest to him so he
didn't end up like Clark which we'll get
into in a second the actor was also too
tall to play a dwarf so to mitigate the
use of CGI in some scenes he was stuck
on his knees poor guy that doesn't sound
comfortable given we know how long
filming can take sometimes number three
sometimes situations evolve it's best to
take extra precautions stunt performer
Dana Grant had a serious head injury
after being scanned she found out she
had an eight millimeter brain aneurysm
and an upper spinal injury she had to go
for immediate brains surgery following
the situation it was not reported to
work safe because someone close to the
production said that at the time it was
diagnosed as a mild concussion and that
isn't considered a notifiable event
according to work safe one person said
Dana's concussion happened because she
was made to do Maneuvers she was
uncomfortable with another famous New
Zealand actor Lucy Lawless helped raise
one hundred thousand dollars for Dana's
emergency surgery number four we're not
sure how that bolt got there but it
caused some serious Havoc another stunt
performer Alyssa Cadwell fell into a
water tank as part of a stunt but her
head wound ended up striking a bolt on
the way down a witness said that the
injuries were traumatic she was paid
five hundred thousand dollars by Amazon
supposedly the payment was to cover the
expenses for cadwell's care and to
return home and was not a lawsuit payoff
situation supposedly number five it's
easy enough to twist a wrist while doing
literally nothing we can't say we're
surprised by this the final stunt
performer to be seriously hurt was
Thomas kiwi who injured the rotator cuff
in his right shoulder so bad that he
left the production he said that he was
required to perform backflip stunts with
an improperly rigged support wire system
he just kept getting caught on the wires
he mentioned the problem but it didn't
get addressed I corrected him directly
after it happened the next day I said
this is what you got wrong they should
be more onto it because there's a lot of
[ __ ] that's happening in the stunt
department and a lot of unsafe stuff
that's happened I just left he did a
whole extra day of work after the
incident before he ever even saw the
doctor number six living with big feet
is a pain in General trying to find cute
shoes your size must be a nightmare the
hard foot feet were irritating the
actors that's a small gripe compared to
hitting your head off of a bolt under
water though we're safe Sarah's
wongobani who played Marigold Brandy
foot said I found out I got a job on one
of the biggest shows on the planet and I
go to costuming and I was like what am I
going to be wearing it's going to be
amazing and they put me in this big
skirt and feet and I was covered in mud
the whole time so that was a bit of a
come down and we bet super itchy too she
continued the prosthetic feet were a bit
challenging at first but we had this
incredible team of people who kept
refining them and by the end they became
part of us and we didn't want to take
them off number seven sounds like
there's an uprising going on a story
about one injury that was never made
public told by another stunt performer
an unnamed stunt performer tore a
ligament so said the other stunt
performer it's a different League being
hushed up from normal injury rates on
film sets number eight hype is a
dangerous thing if not handled with care
before Clark ever even made her way to
set she was injuring herself or well
nearly so she passed out upon finding
out she'd been cast in the show you kind
of see me wandering off slightly
glassy-eyed
and then I was caught by a security
guard in the middle of a q a for another
show or so she said imagine keeping that
secret number nine don't stress the
little stuff sure that's a great motto
in some cases this Series has a ton of
stunts in it of course and risk analysis
was performed whenever necessary with
all near misses and accidents going on
record Heatley said we have had 16 200
stunt person days worked since we
started production our injury rate
across all Studios is 0.065 percent most
of these injuries are common
stunt-related sprains bruises and muscle
and soft tissue strains number 10. who
says acting isn't hard work long hours
over long filming periods can lead to
burnout acting may seem easy from the
outside but that isn't the case at all
Ismail had gone through so much grueling
physical work he said he was comatose
and couldn't even go and hang out with
Clark we imagine the physical stress of
working on a show like the rings of
power would be enough to knock you on
your butt for a few days number 11. so
here's a silly story the cast was
playing a hybrid game of football tennis
between tanks the players must score
goals by hitting the ball over a short
net and well while the cast may be good
at wielding weapons and climbing
mountains Ismail and morbid were
terrible at the game just absolutely
Dreadful and would fake injuries to get
out of playing the only real thing that
was hurt here was their pride number 12.
we feel like we've put you in a
miserable mood so let's end this thing
on a high note in an uplifting moment of
healing Clark as a child was never able
to ride horses because her mom did her
back in riding one so you can imagine it
was a huge challenge for the actor to
climb on a horse for herself when she
got to set and got to climb on a horse
and then got extra time on the horses
thanks to the pandemic she fell in love
with the animal Clark recalls that
riding her horse Titan led to one of the
most beautiful things she'd ever
experienced saying I remember there was
one time when some sort of butterflies
had just hatched there was just a load
of them around me while I was riding him
and I was just like this can't be real
surely life can't be this beautiful the
rings of power has definitely had its
fair share of dangerous stunts and we
honestly don't think we have the stomach
for most of it would you be willing to
do that underwater scene to be part of
the Lord of the Rings Universe let us
know in the comments and thanks for
hanging out with us here at the things